sur la côte sujet nous sommes force de
proposition et donc simplement c'est
circulez ya rien à voir
il faut l'unité nationale et bien encore
une fois c'est non parce que il faut un
moment qu'on accepte de regarder la
situation on peut dire mais tout ça
c'est du passé d'accord mais comment les
huit mois ont été gérés le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est avec beaucoup
d'approximations et d'amateurisme donc
aujourd'hui moi je suis prêt à prendre
ma part de responsabilité simplement il
faut qu'on travaille sur des mesures
concrètes et qu'on soit nous sommes
d'accord alors il suit le gouvernement
direction pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne
cible pas les personnes sensibles la
première raison c'est qu'on a eu encore
une fois désolé de le dire quatre mois
de retard sur les tests massif par
rapport à nos voisins
donc on peut aussi organiser un ciblage
qui me sens qui permet effectivement de
pouvoir isoler les personnes les
personnes testées
ensuite la fermeture des restaurants
il ya des conséquences dramatiques vous
évoquez sur le plan économique mais
regardées par les jeunes comment se
comporte la plupart des jeunes si vous
leur ferme et les restaurants les bars
ont ils se retrouvent ils sont elles
habitent souvent en colocation il se
retrouve au lieu d'être à 5 à 10 dans la
coloc et passent la soirée ensemble donc
on a là des kloster qui vont se
développer alors qu'on a des
professionnels qui étaient prêts à
pouvoir des règles même peut-être plus
drastiques moi je pense oui
la concertation c'est ça et c'est un
ancien syndicaliste qui dit à un moment
si on veut dire qu'on conserve son
travail avec les gens avec les
fédérations professionnelles et on leur
dit écoutez votre système ne marche pas
donc imaginer des règles plus dures au
strict et on va travailler ensemble pour
mettre plus de distance etc
et ça ça n'est pas fait et c'est le
reproche que je fais au président de la
république qui s'entoure de trois
conseillers tout seul et qui décrète les
choses et qui dit après silence dans les
rangs parce que maintenant il faut
l'unité nationale l'heure est grand et
ben non c'est sûr lève le révélateur de
ce qui vient de se passer depuis huit 8
ou 10 mois
c'est quand même eu un manque
d'anticipation total une grande forme
d'improvisation
vingt-cinq mille lits de réanimation en
allemagne
on n'est pas melbourne en allemagne chez
nos voisins six mille 5000 et quel
rythme en france
non mais tout à fait mars et cette norme
on dit que c'est pas possible mais
simplement en avril le ministre monsieur
véran nous annonce vous le retrouverez
annonce qu'il va y avoir quatorze mille
lits
rien n'a été créé pendant pendant cette
période absolument rien qu'aujourd'hui
on est contraint à des mesures très
strictes parce que l'hôpital est en
difficulté pour faire face or pourquoi
le ministre de la santé il ya huit mois
nous annonce doit y avoir quatorze mille
litres c'est possible pourquoi par
exemple au royaume uni le premier
ministre décide de créer des hôpitaux de
campagne et ont créé 4000 lits et qu'on
est incapable de le faire en france je
prends pas l'exemple de la chine je
pense celui du royaume uni
je sais c'est plus proche de nous et
c'est ça le reproche qui est qui est
fait